yeah every guitar has a story my name is
Rick Kelly I custom make guitars here at
carmine Street guitars I make guitars
from reclaimed lumber all new york city
building wood from two hundred year old
trees most of the wood is being thrown
away so i just dumpster dive for it the
craft of it is is one of my favorite
things you know building from the
materials that are historic and coming
up with instruments that make music and
are kind of alive in a different way
it's a lot of you know steps involved I
bring the wood here man then I have to
Dean a lit and then surface it and cut
it to shape on the bandsaw sanded smooth
and then I use a mostly shellac finishes
which is a natural finish a lot of
people have come through carmine street
guitars and bought my custom guitars
over the years Bob Dylan Lou Reed how do
you Smith and Roger Waters Steely Dan
band so many other bands to be able to
give life back into the instrument from
the old Timbers that built this city is
a wonderful feeling to be able to make
it have a new life and turn into
something that makes music it's
wonderful